-My first guest is a very
talented actor and producer
who's written
this new children's book
called "The One
and Only Sparkella,"
which is available now.
Here is Channing Tatum!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, that's --
That's what I'm
talking about, buddy.
Oh, it's so good to see you.
-Good to see you, too, bro.
What's up?
-I missed you, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
It's great to see you.
You look fantastic.
-Thanks, man.
-I got to say, a lot of people
have talked about
gaining weight
during this pandemic.
You've actually gotten
in better shape than ever.
-I did, I did. You know,
for the first like
I'd say week or two weeks,
I definitely was just drinking
beers and riding dirt bikes.
And I was like, "I can't do this
for like two months.
Like, this is bad."
And then me and my buddy, we
just went really, really hard.
We just started training
every day.
And it was great.
I mean, I came out
a completely new person.
-Yeah. I --
How big did you get drinking
beers and riding dirt bikes?
-Pretty fat,
I would say probably,
you know, college 10,
a nice 10 pounds.
And then I took it off.
-Yeah. I saw you posted
this photo right here.
It said, "Daddy is finally back.
Let's go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like looking in a mirror.
It's really --
For me, it's so bizarre.
[ Laughter ]
But you -- You got in shape
for this movie "Dog."
-Yeah.
-Is that right? Now, this is --
You produced this
but also directed this
or co-directed this. What --
-Yeah. I don't know
if I'll be doing that again.
If I ever direct again,
I definitely won't
be in the movie.
And we were like the first of
I think there was three movies
that got going right after
the first quarantine,
so we were the Guinea pigs
of trying to figure out
the protocols and everything.
We were just burning money.
-Oh, my God.
-But we got through it.
I only got bit like six
or seven times by the dogs.
So it was fun.
It was a great experience.
-Yeah, of course it is.
-I would love to do it again.
-Yeah. You're about to do
a movie with Sandra Bullock.
-Yeah.
-And that I'm excited about.
She is --
She's awesome, by the way.
Have you worked with her before?
-I've never worked with her.
Our kids went
to preschool together,
and that was like the most --
You get to understand
really quickly
why she is
at the level that she is.
She's so smart.
She's so engaged.
She's producing this thing,
so I just get to show up
and try to remember my lines
and not get bit by her
and --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, hopefully, you don't get
bit again on this movie, yeah.
I want to talk about
your children's book here.
This is
"The One and Only Sparkella."
I loved it. I can't wait
to read it to my daughters.
-That's awesome.
-Was this inspired
by your daughter?
-Yeah. You know,
my daughter, Everly,
she's just such
a little contrarian.
And since she was like a baby,
she would always just go to
the most colorful thing, to
the most magical-looking thing.
And she liked
to wear funny things
that would make people laugh.
And then one day,
I remember we were in preschool,
and she had this, like, cape,
this watermelon cape.
When you held your arms
out like this,
you look like
a slice of watermelon.
And she just thought it was
the funniest thing in the world.
And when we were about to go
to preschool this one morning,
she got really self-conscious
when we were about to leave
and wanted to take it off.
And I was like,
"What's going on?"
And she's like,
"I don't want to get laughed at.
I don't want people
to laugh at me."
And it sort of broke my heart,
'cause I had never seen her
be self-conscious
or aware even
of other people's perspectives.
And it was beautiful
to, like, know
that I got to be there for her
and kind of help her through it.
And that's kind of
where the book came from.
And just like for dads,
you know --
I was really nervous
to be a girl dad.
First thing I did when I figured
I was going to have a girl,
I literally went to YouTube
and learned how to braid hair,
just 'cause I didn't
want to be that dad
that dropped their kid off --
-Dude, me, too. I bought a book.
I bought a book
on braiding hair.
-Yeah.
-I had no idea.
-It's not easy,
and it takes a long time.
The hardest thing is getting
the three equal strands.
-Yes, yes, no, yes, I know.
It's -- Yes. It's unbelievable.
-Then they make it harder
with, like, layered hair,
and you're just like, "Uh."
And then you would
get halfway through it,
and you're realizing
one is way too short
and you have to start all over.
It's silly.
-I think you're
a pretty awesome dad.
That's the one thing I did like,
too, at the beginning here, too,
you kind of say, "Hey,
for any dads out there,
this is just a --
Just be with your daughter
and actually get to know her."
And you posted this
on Instagram.
It made me laugh.
And this is like --
-Oh, no.
-I've never done
quite this, but --
[ Laughter ]
This is a blindfold makeup?
What do you do with Everly?
-Yeah, we --
Look, we --
-[ Laughs ]
-I am subjected
to all kinds of things.
But that is actually weirdly
one of my favorite games
that we play.
I know this might be shocking.
But you literally
blindfold each other,
and then you do
the other person's makeup,
and then you style them,
and then you do, like,
fashion shows around the pool,
and people vote to see
who did it better.
[ Laughter ]
-See, I can't do my daughters'
nails even not blindfolded.
[ Laughter ]
-No. It's an impossible task.
-Oh, yes.
-Like, I think
that's kind of the point.
I just draw on her face
with everything.
I just --
-And she does that to you.
Yeah, it's fun.
I love the message
behind the book,
and congrats,
and I'm glad you wrote this.
Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you, man.
-Channing Tatum.
"The One and Only Sparkella"
is available now.